the medical industry is becoming a
popular target for hackers experts say
it's all about profits hackers on
average can sell credit card numbers for
ten to fifteen cents each but a medical
record could be worth anywhere between
thirty and five hundred dollars for
Monday CBS n on assignment Reena Ninan
visited a hospital in Buffalo New York
where hackers took down the computer
system for six weeks here's a preview
some here at Erie County Medical Center
it's a level one trauma center their
entire system was hacked the medical
industry is the new number one target
for hackers almost all US healthcare
organizations have reported at least one
cyber attack and the largest American
Hospital hack this year was this 550 bed
facility in Buffalo
all the screens were black all the
computer screens were turned off that's
pretty ominous all blacks mean
everything we had and normally used yes
was essentially unplug the system dr.
Jennifer Pugh runs the ER she was on
staff the morning hackers sent this
ransomware message demanding forty four
thousand dollars in the cyber currency
Bitcoin to unlock hospital data of being
held hostage they went back to pen and
paper for six weeks until the systems
were back online I think it's it's
disgusting
they're attacking some of the most
vulnerable members of society by coming
after a hospital this is a form of
terrorism this is these are criminals in
our case we decided not to pay that
ransom but make no mistake about it this
definitely affected our organization and
it's going to cost us a lot of you know
a lot of money in the long run Tomas
Quattro Chi is the hospital CEO the US
government has a long-standing policy
when terrorists kidnap Americans you
don't pay a ransom should that be the
same case when they steal medical
records well I think every hospital has
to make their own decision so let me
tell you why we didn't it was a matter
of integrity for the institution
[Music]
rage Harnish leads a cybersecurity firm
that got Erie County hospital systems
back online
he says attacks like these are just the
beginning I think it gets a little
scarier from here honestly
imagine that physicians clinical staff
nurses came in one day and instead of
the data being encrypted or unavailable
he was all wrong prescriptions allergies
which leg to amputate imagine that all
of the data in the EMR was actually just
wrong and you didn't know which data was
wrong and you can see Riina's full
report Monday night on the next cbsn on
assignment it airs at 10:00 9:00 central
here on CBS and on our streaming network
CBS n